once again the country is struggling to
understand acts of mass gun violence
after deadly attacks in two more
American cities and overnight the FBI
issued a new warning saying quote
violent extremists could become inspired
by these and previous high-profile
attacks to engage in similar acts of
violence the massacres in El Paso Texas
and Dayton Ohio happened in startling
proximity for a country already too
familiar with gun violence twenty nine
people were killed in the two shooting
rampages just 13 hours apart these are
some of the faces and names of those
killed the victims ranged in age from 15
to 86 the Justice Department says it is
treating the attack at the El Paso
Walmart as domestic terrorism at least
20 people were killed and 26 others were
hurt that toll makes it the eighth worst
mass shooting in modern American history
the 21 year old suspect is in custody
more than 1300 miles away in Dayton Ohio
at least nine people were killed in 27
wounded just after 1:00 a.m. Sunday
police officer shot and killed the
gunman less than 30 seconds after he
first opened fire
president Trump condemned the shootings
and said quote hate has no place in our
country